but that ding looking despondent i mean
is there any chance for ding to maybe
defend the pawn that's under attack
can he get away with that
um maybe he'll have to try it it draws
the same as the lost right right
so white knight in the middle of the
board it can actually retreat to defend
uh black is threat he does it black was
threatening
actually i think there might even be
some sacrifices in the air
yeah and the cannon the knight can jump
forward and give us a check
okay tonight takes pawn so ding here can
still
maybe make a draw if he just gives
checks with the white queen back and
forth back and forth but look at this
the evaluation bar confirming it that's
the best white can get a draw
it's not good enough if white's knight
captures the black knight if it retreats
then the other black knight will jump in
with a check and that's deadly
it will lead to checkmate and uh just
take a look in the camera at ding that
is the definition of
someone who has lost all hope
and we do see him give a check and
another check will we see him take the
draw
yeah i think we're going to see that
yeah i mean just nothing to do
and he's completely resigned to the
inevitable yeah he's facing a deadly
attack on his own and therefore he has
to force to draw one more check now with
the queen
position repeats itself three times
magnus wins this third place match yep
it's over mine is winning
the first blitz game this one is a draw
so he is the winner of
the third place match